Winston Churchill said that when you're
young if you're not a liberal you don't
have a heart and when you're old if
you're not a conservative you don't have
a brain the Washington Post has an
article out today or this weekend that
indicates similar things Millennials
like socialism is the title of the
article until they get jobs Millennials
are the only age group in America within
which a majority views socialism
favorably a national reason Rupe survey
found that 53 percent of Americans under
age 30 have a favorable view of
socialism compared with less than a
third of those over 30
moreover Gallup has found that an
astounding 69 percent of Millennials say
they'd be willing to vote for a
socialist candidate for president among
their parents generation only one-third
would do so indeed national polls and
exit polls reveal about 70 to 80 percent
of young democrats are casting their
ballots for president presidential
candidate bernie sanders who calls
himself a democratic socialist yet
Millennials tend to reject the actual
definition of socialism government
ownership of the means of production or
government running businesses only 32
percent of Millennials favor and economy
managed by the government so are they
socialist or aren't they just lacking in
knowledge of the basic definitions hmm
that's interesting and as Millennials
age and begin to earn more their
socialistic ideals seem to slip away
according to the data coming of age
during the Great Recession Millennials
aren't sure if free markets are
sufficient to drive income mobility and
thus many are comfortable with
government helping to provide for
people's needs a recent study found this
sixty-nine percent of Millennials favor
a government guarantee for health
insurance and 54 percent support a
guarantee for a college education so
will that last
our Millennials assuring in a seat
public opinion they signal the
transformation of the United States into
a Scandinavian social democracy well it
depends there is some evidence that this
generations views on activist government
will stick however there is more reason
to expect that for this candidate for
the Scandinavian version of socialism
may wither as they age and make money
and pay more in taxes the expanded
social welfare state Sanders thinks the
United States should adopt requires
everyday people to pay considerably more
in taxes yet Millennials become adverse
averse to social welfare spending if
they foot the bill as they reach the
threshold of earning forty to fifty
forty to sixty thousand dollars a year
the majority of Millennials come to
oppose income redistribution including
raising taxes to increase financial
assistance to the poor similarly the
research poll found that while
Millennials still on their parents
health insurance policies supported the
idea of paying higher premiums to help
cover the uninsured 57% support flipped
57 percent supported higher premiums
while they were on their parents
policies support flipped among
Millennials paying for their own health
insurance with fifty nine percent
opposed to higher premiums when tax
rates are not explicit Millennials say
they'd prefer larger government offering
more services that's fifty four percent
um said that to smaller government
offering fewer services forty three
percent
however when larger government offering
more services is described as requiring
higher taxes support flips and 57
percent of Millennials opt for smaller
government with fewer services and lower
taxes sounds like a conservative or
something well only 41 percent at that
point prefer large government see I'm 55
years old and I am a huge fan of the
millennial generation and I'm so that
makes me a little bit unusual
my age group that reads articles like
this and where they're feeling the burn
and all that stuff I've got a whole
bunch of Millennials working for me on
our team and I hear employers when I'm
doing leadership training all over the
United States say Millennials are really
tough to hire the really tough to hire
the really tough to get good ones is
really tough to get good ones listen
it's really tough to get good people I
don't care what generation they are it's
cutting it's tough to get people who are
ambitious who care who are talented who
are passionate who actually work while
they're at work and don't steal that's
just tough of any generation it's not a
racial thing it's not a male/female
thing it's not an age group thing it's
tough to get good people on your team I
got five hundred and sixty of them in
here and they're good people and if one
up midden they'll be gone soon it's a
tough thing to run a business and get
good people and we love Millennials here
because there's only two types awesome
and sucks and they tell you they're real
honest I suck I believe in the Bern and
I want you to give me free stuff and I'm
going to sit on my butt because I was
born on third base and I think I hit a
triple they'll tell you that or they
come in here and go in you're changing
the world Dave and I want to be part of
something that's changing the world
you're saving marriages and people are
getting out of debt and changing family
trees and I'm a crusader and man I want
to be on board on something like that
and they plug in here and now out work a
baby boomer three to one because they
care so deeply they're Crusaders I love
them
I think Millennials are awesome but what
this article is pointing out is is when
you have to pay the bill to go with your
philosophies when you have to write a
check put your dadgum money where your
mouth is it suddenly puts your
philosophies to the test
it changes your philosophies from
something that's real when you have to
look at your children and make decisions
about your children because what you're
sending to Washington goes up called
taxes that's different than sitting
around a campfire smoking weed and
discussing philosophy it's different
everybody is a dadgum philosopher when
they don't have to provide the checks
everybody's an economist until they
start writing the checks may give you an
example I'm 55 as I said so the kids
that babysitter's that were my
babysitter's the girls in the
neighborhood that were six you
years older than me which would put them
in their 60s now that was the hippie
generation that was the long hair
burning flags protesting the Vietnam War
they were a bunch of Communists not
socialists they believed in calm
communes were popping up you want it let
me just tell you it's very difficult to
find anyone that is much more of a
capitalist than an old hippie you meet
an old hippie in their 60s there they're
a Deadhead they're a Grateful Dead fan
you meet an old hippie in their 60s they
are flaming capitalists they figured out
through the scope of their life that
communism is failed event it's a failed
system and they adopted the best system
on earth which is capitalism same thing
will happen to the misguided Millennials
once they start writing the checks
that's what this data shows there's
great hope for this nation don't be
disappointed in this younger generation
they're just they're following their
heart rather than their brain it'll come
to them they're they're good at they're
good people they're gonna we're going to
be all right America Bernie's not going
to get elected don't you worry
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you